hey what's up guys my name is jonah
welcome back to my game engine series
the last time we began our 2d physics
journey check out that video if you
haven't already it's a pretty long one
but there's a lot of good content i
think in there i've tried to condense it
as much as possible and that's kind of
the plan from here on out point is
though we are on this kind of 2d physics
journey and that's kind of our overall
goal now to get 2d physics to the point
where it like basically is fully
implemented everything works all that
stuff but to get there the next kind of
roadblock that we have is the fact that
we need to be able to hit play
to play our scene and then obviously
when we hit stop we wanted to kind of
reset so what actually needs to happen
is we need to be able to create like a
runtime version of our scene that is
like completely mutable meaning it's
completely changeable you know there's
no kind of state there that we need to
worry about resetting it has to have its
own separate kind of memory ultimately
and state but then when we hit stop we
want to kind of go back to that like
editor scene right the scene that we
were editing the scene like as it
appears without any kind of disruptions
without any runtime modifications
meaning like we haven't hit play yet so
there's no simulation everything is as
we authored it in the editor that is
kind of like that that's our next kind
of step here that's our next goal
because obviously since the last episode
if you remember when we hit play
you know everything fell and then we hit
stop and then the objects remained in in
that place because really by hitting
play we just say physics goes starts
simulating
so then it changes everything and then
obviously nothing kind of reverts that
or resets it back to its kind of
serialized state so that is basically
where we are at right now that's our
next kind of goal
so to get there though there are a few
things that need to be done now as i
mentioned last time and this just is
this kind of applies from here on out we
are fully live streaming pretty much all
of the development of this hazel 2d
engine that we're working on on twitter
tv slash the churno right so everything
is always live streamed every single
thursday there there's a link in the
description so you can catch that stream
and if you actually watch that vod
there's actually two i streamed twice
yesterday i streamed like in the morning
and i just had to go and then stream
later as well but the point is we got we
got basically all of this working so if
you want to peek ahead then feel free to
actually go through that and see how it
was done but what we're going to do is
obviously these videos are going to kind
of take everything step by step so
in order to do like the play thing that
i mentioned and to actually be able to
like revert scenes and you know properly
handle runtime scenes we actually need
to implement something else and that's
what today is going to be about today is
going to be about universally unique
identifiers or globally unique
identifiers uuids goods whatever you
want to call them
it's
finally time for us to actually
implement this in our game engine
because we haven't had this yet
and as you'll see it's going to become a
little bit of a problem when we want to
kind of make sure that you know editor
entities and runtime entities are kind
of the same now i do want to quickly
note though that if you are like if i
boot up hazel here this is where we left
off quick little side note as well keep
in mind we are currently on the physics
branch the dev branch is everything that
goes on during the live stream so in
other words the stuff that we've
actively worked on and that i've kind of
committed everything that i've done
basically all the code that i wrote
during that live stream yesterday has
been pushed to dev but officially you
know if you want to keep up with the
videos these videos on youtube they're
on the physics branch so just keep an
eye out on that so as i was saying if we
boot up hazel at the moment and we you
know we hit play obviously this bounces
around and we hit stop if we want to
reset the scene one thing we could do as
like a really easy quick fix is just
load the scene again right because if
you deserialize it again from disk
assuming you haven't hit you know
control s now actually control s doesn't
even work we'll address that a little
bit later we're going to have like a
kind of maintenance episode where we
just do a lot of you know low hanging
fruit kind of easy tasks that aren't
going to take us much time and aren't
worth putting into a separate episode
but anyway the point is as long as you
don't like overwrite your save right
you're saved scene if you deserialize it
again of course you're going to go back
to the original scene that's like a
little quick fix of doing it but we
don't really want to do that because
obviously we might be like working and
stuff like that so instead what we
usually want to do and we'll talk about
that more probably in the next episode
is we want to actually spin off a new
scene so we need the ability to copy
scenes
we want to have this kind of editor
scene and then for runtime we need to
create like a new runtime scene it's
capable of doing stuff it's going to be
a temporary kind of scene that we create
like while our actual game is in the the
play state and it basically gets deleted
as soon as we hit stop right so in order
to do that though um as i mentioned we
need to talk about universally unique
identifiers so when it comes to uuids
right uh this this and that's what i
kind of want to talk about today because
there's a lot that you could say about
it and i don't really want to go
too in-depth into everything that
they're used for but basically this is
this is the point of them right so we
need a way to identify a lot of unique
objects throughout our game engine now
this can refer to entities so when we
create a new entity in the editor that
needs to be identifiable in a unique way
meaning we can't have the same name on
another entity right that id has to be
unique between entities now what about
things like scenes scenes are also
important right what if you have two
scenes with the same name well again you
need to be able to uniquely identify
scenes what about assets how do we know
which texture is which how do we know
which like 3d model if this was a 3d
engine is which right there's all of
these different things like a sound file
right anything basically that exists in
the engine needs some kind of identifier
so
again the reason we don't usually use
names for this is because
it's very possible to have you know two
entities that are called the same thing
and and i don't really necessarily want
to place that restriction that like
every time you create an entity you have
to make a unique name for it like that's
a bit weird even if you did have the
engine automate that process meaning if
you tried to call something box it would
call it box 2 that's still obviously
just weird you just you don't want to
think about that a name should not be
the thing that uniquely identifies the
object right assets another great
example assets by file path there's a
lot we'll talk more about this when we
get to the asset manager asset system
videos but uh we don't really want to
identify assets by their file path for a
number of reasons right not only because
they might get packaged and zipped and
compressed and the path might change
entirely and we might have to be dealing
with like virtual paths but also because
if we update an asset or we want to move
it somewhere else we want to be able to
identify it in a way that doesn't
concretely tie it to a specific file
path because that shouldn't be the thing
that you know is kind of not flexible
immutable and stays the same right file
paths should be flexible anyway so um
that being said right instead of using
all of those kind of systems like names
and file parts instead we use
universally unique identifiers so what
they typically are right oh and the
biggest question i think that a lot of
people usually have is like why do we
need this weird kind of uuid good system
that's like you know you know if we were
to like type it out you know we'd have
like an id
of like you know that right why does it
have to be this why can't i just start
started started at zero and every time i
create a new entity or a new asset i
increment this well you could do that
right there's nothing
too terrible with that in a local sense
but the reason why we usually generate a
random number like this is because
consider this scenario right what if you
are working on your scene and creating
entities and then someone else on their
own computer is working on the same game
as you right because games aren't
usually built by one person on one
computer although of course they can be
right what if they also create new
entities
well then who's handing out the ids
there has to be some kind of authority
like a server or something that that
makes sure that you can't create you
can't both create entities at the same
time right because again if you're just
incrementing it then locally you're
gonna create five entities you'll have
id five six seven eight taken up but
then someone else on their computer is
also going to create four entities and
they're gonna occupy ideas five six
seven eight and then when you go to
merge the scene together nothing makes
sense right even if it's in a different
scene right it could be an asset that's
used in both scenes well again you have
the problem of
if there's no authority checking this
then
we'll we'll have a conflict basically if
we just increment now of course as i
mentioned you could have a server that
dishes out an id you request an id from
the server and then like you know it's
like okay you asked first i'll give you
six and this other guy's getting seven
instead to avoid conflicts we don't want
to set up a server to issue ids right
that does work in some scenarios and it
is used in some scenarios but usually we
don't want to do that instead if we
generate this very random number that is
at least like you know long enough right
then the possibility throughout a
development cycle of a game
right for us for me and then the person
working like behind me
right to generate the same exact number
it's just not gonna happen right the the
possibility for a conflict is very low
it's still possible right but it's very
low
so hopefully that kind of answers the
questions of why we need uuids right
we refer to them as uuids uuids and
we'll we'll talk a little bit more about
the implementation in a minute but uuid
is good you know they basically mean the
same thing and again that's why they're
kind of called universally unique or
globally unique because they're so
unique like to the point where it's fine
for you to generate one it's fine for
someone else to generate one you can
generate multiple at the same time they
can be across different computers there
doesn't have to be an authority because
it's so kind of
random right it's so unlikely for you to
generate the same number as someone else
that it's totally fine to like not
necessarily use some kind of authority
right and again it is basically
guaranteed to in fact be a unique number
so that's basically all it is right it's
our quest to generate a unique number so
that we can identify something inside
our game engine so hopefully that kind
of explanation makes sense uh and
hopefully you now also see why we can't
just you know increment a number like 0
1 2 3 4 and use that as as the id like
and does actually entity the the kind of
library that we're using for the entity
component system that does have ids like
zero one two three it's not really meant
to be used over like multiple computers
or anything but again and that's also
subject to change right as in like if
you
uh were to recreate all the entities
again you'd get different ids uh because
it's it's a bit weird like it's it's not
weird but it's just like it's not meant
to be like an identifier for a
particular entity and nc is just like an
index into a set of components basically
so anyway um that hopefully makes sense
let's dive in and take a look at how
we're going to create this by the way i
want to quickly point out also that we
basically have already made room for
this stuff which is really nice i was
very happy when i discovered this during
the live stream yesterday like we
already have you know u164t here uuid
equals entity as uid so we're
deserializing here and i think we also
have
um the other part of this
uh i think it might be marked with like
a to do yeah here it is ntid goes here
and we have this like a random value
here right so we've already kind of
prepared it which is nice that's where
we're going to store entity ids here but
again this is something that's going to
exist across like not just like the
entity component system in parentheses
and a way for us to identify entities
right but it's also going to serve um
you know at the asset system and like
the scene system and a lot of different
things basically okay so the first thing
i want to do is if we pop into hazel i'm
just going to mark this as like the show
all files mode so that we can actually
like see the folder structure because i
want to make sure that i make this in
the core folder
i'm going to call this uid because again
it is going to be something that's
obviously very core to the engine
and this class
so namespace hazel we'll make it a class
we'll call it uuid
so um
this uh okay so the implementation of
uuid we need to talk about what it is at
its core and basically in hazel what i'm
gonna do is for now i'm going to make it
a un-64 t and this is going to be like
the actual uuid now a uuid or a good
like traditionally is supposed to be a
128 bit value
why that's just usually how it's defined
if we want to create a 128 bit value we
have a few options of course we could
compose it from 264 bit values and then
generate it using like a random number
generator or something like that
typically random number generators in
the c plus standard library as far as
i'm aware i only go up to 64 bits so if
you generated two and combined them like
you wouldn't get the best kind of
behavior we'll say it's usually not the
best way to do things
every platform usually has a way to
generate an actual uuid for you so if
you actually want a 128-bit value
then
i think like windows has something like
create good or like i don't know there's
a win32 api function that will create
that for you so that's one route you
could absolutely take uh here on the
cherno show we like to not complicate
things too much and like in my
experience a 64-bit random kind of uuid
for the purposes of a game engine and
for our purposes so far
has been enough right i in in using this
for like over a year and working on
projects across different computers of
like in using hazel 3d using the big
hazel
i've never had anything like close to a
conflict right uh like it's just
to generate two identical random 64-bit
numbers that's very unlikely right it is
still possible if you have millions of
entities and you know tens of millions
hundreds of millions of entities right
um and that's why like it's important to
consider the fact that if you you know
uuid is
if you if you picture assets if you
picture entities that you create
yourself well
again it's not it's probably not
something that you'll ever exceed right
you'll probably never get to the point
where it becomes likely or even slightly
possible to get a collision
but
but
um if you are if you have made an
application in hazel that inside the
script
you know creates just millions of
entities per frame
right and assuming the ecs can keep up
with that and everything
of course you may run into a collision
if pro if programmatically you're
dishing out that many uuids like per
second or whatever so you know i'm not
going to say that it's completely
nothing to worry about but for now this
is how we're going to treat it now um
we're going to obviously we're going to
end up storing uids in maps which means
we basically need to hash them so i'm
going to include xhash instead of trying
to include like stdint.h to get this to
not be an error because we are going to
have to hash them um and we'll talk
about that in a minute it's obviously
very easy to hash this because it's just
a um 64t
so how do we create them and what's the
api going to be like well
the way the the api is going to work is
just by running the constructor it's
going to automatically generate a uuid
right that's kind of the way that i've
designed the api so in other words if
you just if you just write code such as
uuid id like that it's going to give you
an id right
if you want 0 you can explicitly write
zero for something that is deliberately
marked as not initialized or something
like that
um so that's kind of how we're going to
do it and then yeah you can take in like
an id or something like that if you
really want to right so this can be like
your uuid
uh you know copy constructors i don't
even know why i kind of entertained the
idea of having a copy constructor here
i've got some like sample code that i
read during the stream but basically if
you wanted to you could make it kind of
deliberately uh
copy constructor but again all that's
going to do is shallow copy this because
that's all we really need to do to copy
it so that's basically our uuid class
right so how we're going to generate
this random number
well we're going to use c plus as random
number generators right so um let's
include
uh uuid
namespace hazel
and let's take a look at this so
basically i think this is all inside
random i'm not 100 sure but i think it
is all in here so basically if we go
back and we implement like the stuff
that we needed to implement the method
implementations here
then obviously our goal here is to just
generate a uuid and then store it so how
are we going to do that well we're going
to use a couple of things as i mentioned
from the civil c standard library we're
going to mark them as static right we'll
talk about this stuff in a minute but
basically we're going to use something
called random device and i'll explain
this once i type it out then we're going
to use this engine that simplest comes
with which is called mt 1937 but we're
gonna use the underscore 64 version
because otherwise we'll get a 32-bit
random value which is of course useless
um to us so i wouldn't recommend 32-bit
uids that actually you know having 4.4
point what is it 4.6 or 4.3 i've
forgotten
what's 2 to the power of 32. anyway
having like 4 billion-ish um random ids
is not not much uh because again it's
it's not that we need four billion ids
it's that we want to reduce the
possibility of generating two ids that
that are the same across like computers
and everything
right so this is gonna be um you know s
uh we'll call this engine and then we're
going to take an s random device with
the call operator over here to
initialize that again this is all going
to be initialized statically i don't
really need to care about this too much
and then we'll use this uniform in
distribution this is going to be the
thing un-64t that actually distributes
i'll call this s uniform distribution
this is going to be the thing that
actually distributes well gets us the
random value
so um let's talk about this a little bit
well this is just the way that you
generate random numbers in c plus
there's not much to it if you want to
dive into it a little bit more and see
what's going on you can see that it's
using the mercen messen mesen i don't
know how to pronounce that twister
engine right so that's specifically what
it's doing
and again you can look into it a little
bit more i'm not an expert on random
number generation this seems to be
pretty good as in my experience and
again the most important thing is that
you are using the 64-bit version uh
because we are we have a 64-bit good
right so that's important so how do we
generate a round number well it's super
easy in fact we can just do it up here
so we're going to set this to be s
uniform distribution
and then we pass in the engine right
which obviously is s on the score engine
and that's it
so a few issues with this right um well
okay there's two issues i just want to
mention because i did this again on oh
my computer turned on i hate it when
computers turn on randomly you know it
really
i started like shutting the psu off on
my main computer like overnight because
it would just wake up sometimes anyway
so excuse this guy behind me i really
need to turn him off anyway whatever
sorry so
um
again because i live stream this and i
write and i plan all this code during
live streams it's actually pretty good
because i kind of have a list of
questions that people ask that i'm going
to convey to you now if you don't want
to watch that whole stream but basically
one of the things that people said were
uh okay so what what if you did have
something to prevent collision though
again it's really unlikely but what if
you did have something to prevent
collision and someone suggested having
like a hash map
so having like an unordered map i mean i
guess you could just have an unordered
set right if you had an unordered set of
uuid or un64t same thing right uh if you
had an unordered set of all this
of all these hashes that you want hashes
but of all these ids that you gave out
right can you just quickly generate it
and then basically validate it to be
like well if i can find that id in here
then maybe try again
uh i wouldn't recommend doing this
there's a couple of reasons first of all
it will obviously add like a little
layer of complexity and some more kind
of performance cost to generate uids not
that we care about that too much
predominantly the reason is that the
reason i wouldn't do this is because
uh i think the the risk of a collision
is low enough that we don't need this
system and furthermore clearly this is
local right meaning that if someone else
generates a uuid behind me again i
always keep using this example but
whatever
if someone generates a uuid on my same
project
on a different computer this is gonna do
nothing right so in other words like
it's not really a solution
um so i wouldn't like i wouldn't bother
with any of that complexity right the
other thing was uh
threading right what about
is this thread safe
i don't actually know if this library
itself a thread safe is thread safe you
could make thread local versions of
these if you wanted to
the reason why i'm not bothering with
that at the moment i mean first of all
we don't have
threads anyway here we don't like what's
a thread right hazel 2 doesn't care
about that at the moment yet it will
move to like a render thread kind of
architecture later
but at the moment it doesn't so it
doesn't care right but the big the
bigger thing is
i don't think
that
any other thread except for the main
thread will ever be responsible for
dishing out uuids right i think that's
going to be only called from the main
thread right and so because of that i'm
not going to bother with that like the
render thread is not going to be doing
it it's possible that some
you know if we if we offload resources
like resource loading to a different
thread and then maybe the asset manager
has a generate uid it's possible that it
does that through the
resource thread or some kind of job
thread right in that case we will need
to think about it
but yeah anyway welcome to the game
engine series the show where we write
five lines of code and then talk about
everything possibly that can happen in
the future
right ridiculous anyway whatever i mean
i'm happy with this guys so just let me
know let me know what you think because
i this series like i don't know i've
given up on this series i've give i've
given up on this series in the sense
that
i like it is just going to be as complex
as it gets it's going to be as these
episodes are going to be as long as they
get i don't care right it's just i my
job is to kind of give you guys as much
information you guys seem to enjoy me
talking about what's in my head and
explaining it to you so
that's just where we are okay now next
step is again as i mentioned it'd be
nice to use these uuids in like
unordered maps uh and in unordered sets
right so in other words we need a hash
function to be able to hash this now
guess what this a uuid what is it it's
literally 64 bits and it's an integer
right very hashable c plus doesn't know
that though so what we have to do is
actually provide a hash function now
it's very easy to provide a hash
function
and again if you're still a little bit
confused as to why we even need this
then uh let's i'll show you why right um
this might be a little soil on how to
write a hash uh function as well another
map is probably something that you're
more familiar with than on another set
but if we have a static void
add to map
let's just say we have a std i've got a
habit of running of writing static
everywhere because i don't like
variables to be global but under the map
um uuid
i don't know entity or something we'll
just say string
uh map right
this is not gonna work right we're not
gonna be able to say like
make me a uuid and then assign it to
cherno right that's not gonna work why
because there's no hash function for
this right um well why is uid undefined
though you for real asks this in hazel
lol okay
i don't know why i did this outside of
the hazelnut space but whatever right
that's not gonna work um it might say
that it does uh but when we actually try
and compile it no i didn't include the
pch
i don't know why it says that it does
though
it's going to tell us that and this is a
very common error that
i get a lot of messages about
attempting to reference a deleted
function and i mean ultimately it just
can't hash it right and if you if you
look at it
um the the point being that ha like it's
gonna work fine if we just treat this as
a un-64 t
right and it's totally reasonable to do
that because uh what what we might do is
we might make this castable let's make
that happen real quick so since the uuid
is just a un64t what we can actually do
is create an operator that will actually
allow us to cast that so i think it's
like operator i don't think we need
constant or anything unct 4t const
return muuid right so this will let us
basically have a have an op it basically
tells us that if we want to treat this
class as a uuid so if we want to cast it
or even implicitly cast it
it's going to return uuid right because
again it's just a wrap up for this one
integer it's important to understand in
c plus and then see that like classes
trucks well more important than c plus
plus possibly because there's a lot more
to classes potentially but
classes in c plus plus they are just the
members right again if it's if you have
a v table et cetera it's different but
they're just members right at the end of
the day this is what the class is and
these functions are just like stored in
other space in the binary right so point
being that we can obviously kind of
treat them as their type in this case if
it's just a thin wrapper like this so by
doing this we've kind of solved the
hashing problem this will work right why
it's turning into a c plus tutorial
anyway why because
you know we can cast this to a unc4t and
everything's great but that's like
slightly annoying right i want to be
able to do that right so how do i do
that well again what you need to do is
just provide unordered map with a
function it can use to hash this because
if it's a key it doesn't know what a
uuid is just some custom class
right i missed this again right it
doesn't know what it is so how is it
supposed to hash it so that the
unordered map works properly same thing
with if we just use a map right instead
of an unordered map we would need to
implement like the less than operator so
that it could actually put it into the
right spot in our tree
um so because of that
uh we need to define this kind of hash
function that's going to be used so how
do we do that well i'm not going to
pretend to remember how to do this
because i always have to look this up
but basically we can just do you have to
do this in this in the std namespace we
can just type instruct hash
um hazel uuid right
and i'll explain this in a minute so
we're creating a we're creating a
template specialization
of a struct
right and a structure is the same as a
class right but this is a specialization
so the hash is kind of a temple oh go
away the hash is a
kind of you know
hash has a template it's like a template
class defined like this but this is us
specializing it just like we would with
the template specialization we've done
template specializations before because
we have this annoying pile of trash
over here right i still during live
streams recently i was like why did i
add this this seems like such garbage
but anyway whatever we'll get back to
that on a different day
um so anyway point being that over here
with the with with this hash it's just
this is just our template specialization
we're providing it with a way to do this
and so for that to work again this is
not my code it's c plus plus a standard
library code i'm just writing a
specialization for their function we
have to implement this kind of call
operator which is just the kind of
parentheses operator right so that when
we call hash on this type right when we
try and hash this type
it's going to return a size t and that's
going to be our hash right and so what
we could do is again if this was a
little bit more complicated like uuid
wasn't just a 64-bit thing then we would
just get it to generate one for us right
and again this i think this has to be a
const reference just because again this
is their function
um
so
and then what we could do is now we just
return our hashing code so how do you
want to create the hash how do you want
how do you want me to hash this value
when you pass in a uuid as a key into
another map for example right and again
because like a uuid is just a 64 bit
value we don't need to hash it ourselves
the c plus plus library provides a hash
function for the 64-bit integer type
right and so because of that we can just
run hash but we can basically just
redirect it to another specialization of
this hash class and that's going to be
this and then again how do we get the
hash from there we just do you and 64t
uuint 604t uuid and that's it right that
uh should basically be it oh except we
have to call this right and then that's
the parameter
okay
so again we're using the call operator
to call
this same function but for un64t and
that's where we're redirecting this to
so that's how we write a hash function
again you just need to create a
specialization of this and this for your
particular type and then do whatever
code you want to generate a hash for it
a little bit confusing uh but this is
going to be a good reference point for
this i don't think we've done this in
the past maybe we have and this has been
a waste of time but anyway
that's it right that is how we that
that's how uuids work and how um we can
basically use them like and how we can
hash them and how we generate them and
hopefully everything you need to know
about uuids okay cool so how do we use
them now in the engine well what i'm
going to do is basically make room for
uids inside entity right so the idea is
and what we're going to use it for
initially is when i create an entity
i want to give it a handle right like i
want to give it this uuid as a unique
identifier as a globally unique
identifier for our entity right so how
do i do that well
we basically need a way to obviously
store it on the entity how do we store
things in the entity as a component
right so we use an ecs which means that
it has to become a component i'm going
to do it as the very first component
here i'm going to call it id component
and then we're going to give it a uuid
and i'll just call it id right and then
i'll copy the same pattern that we've
had over here where we basically have
the
copy constructor and a default
constructor right now we need to include
uid um by the way a quick thing about
includes i don't like
like um i should probably establish some
kind of
uh policy slash style guide here but
usually i like to include our code first
the reason being that well first of all
you should define some kind of order so
that it's not just intertwined right but
the reason why i like our code first is
just in case there's some kind of
configuration files that might have like
macro definitions or you know stuff like
that right defines in them whatever
so that way we can just kind of make
sure that they're actually compiled
first right and then we include the rest
of this code so that this code might be
affected by that code if that makes
sense unless there's like a reason why
we can't do that
anyway so that's how we create an id
component right we can now have that so
it's really important now that every
time we want to create an entity we give
it a uuid so how do we do that well we
have a create entity function right it
has a transform component all i'm going
to do is also get it to add an id
component now that's actually that's it
that's all we have to do right because
by adding an id component it's going to
call the constructor that's that itself
is going to generate a uuid for us
immediately now we'll also need a
function called create entity with uuid
um and the reason that's going to
need to happen is i'll show you in a
minute right is because of the basically
deserializing entities if we want to
create entities in the scene that have
already been
created like because they're just being
deserialized or there's plenty of other
reasons we obviously need to give it a
uuid that we will for example read in
from the actual end from the actual like
deserialization from the actual kind of
yaml file that stores stores all of our
scene
data
so let's serialize it first though how
do we serialize an entity well um
yeah
i'm just thinking about this
no maybe let's oh yeah let's make
civilization work because what i'm going
to do is i'm going to deserialize it get
hazel to generate uuids for all the
entities in our scene just randomly
because we're not using them anyway yet
and then serialize it again the reason
being that i don't want it to
deserialize this number and then put
that in that's going to be a bit weird
so if we want to um get a serialization
working then instead of just using this
i just want to be able to basically ask
the entity hey what's your what's your
id right and we can probably just assert
here that if the entity
if entity has component uid like if
that's not the case if it doesn't have
that uh sorry i you id id component if
it doesn't have an id component then we
don't want to serialize it like it's
probably an error because we're probably
trying to serialize some kind of like
scene meta entity or something weird
right every entity has to have an id
component
um so uh okay so how do we get it well
again you could do entity get component
you uh what is it id component
this is just so annoying though right
getting getting energy's uid such a
trivial task i want to be able to
actually just call get uuid and then
that's going to look up the energy
component system so again we're using
this kind of entity
we're using this kind of like entity
class as just a wrap up for us right to
a wrapper that will do all of the ecs
stuff for us that will just make our
code a little bit simpler so how do we
add that well actually this turned out
to be a little bit confusing during the
live stream because we actually include
scene here
um and
that led to some problems and i'll show
you why in a minute um hopefully it will
i mean it should it still should lead to
problems here anyways the point is if i
want to write a function
called get id
right then what's what's this going to
be it's going to be get component again
we could do it like an assert for house
component but um whatever so get
component id component dot
id right that's what it's going to
return this gives us an error right why
does this give us give us an error
because
uh apparently no
um i just i'm just going to make sure
that i did it correctly i think i did
anyway point being that i think um
but we're including scene aren't we
so actually this probably should work
uh
[Music]
no function template i get
get component id component
ah sorry that's because i marked this as
cons for some reason
yeah it seems to work
get you id unknown syntax error oh uuid
okay well yeah that's that's fine that
we can include uid ui doesn't it doesn't
include anything so we can definitely do
that i wonder what was up
during the live stream
because i feel like either we didn't
have the scene include or
yeah this looks uh here we go id oh this
is the problem sorry i knew there was a
problem
so basically we have to include
components so that we can access
specific components like id component
but unfortunately components includes
scriptable entity which includes entity
so this becomes a bit of a recursive
include components include entity entity
includes components and obviously if we
try and like control f7 this it's not
gonna
work right
so how do we fix it well we basically uh
look at like components shouldn't be
including entity right a component a
component generally doesn't know about
entities however you can see a
scriptable entity is the culprit because
scriptable entity includes entity so
what i'm going to do is not include
scriptable entity here right we use it
over here but what i'm going to do is
i'm just going to you i'm just going to
make a forward declaration for it
because you can see the scriptable
entity is just a pointer anyway so we
can just define it like this right and
then actually include the scriptable
entity class when that pointer needs to
be used right so i'll just do a little
forward declaration
here and i think if we hit compile now
it should work and then i think in scene
it probably won't work
because it doesn't know what it is but
this is where we include it right so
include scriptable
entity
and then it should be okay we get a
static assertion failed because we need
to add this
pile of garbage um
i'm gonna really really rethink this
system this was just a way for me to
basically have a non-component added
function i don't know why
it has to be present though but whatever
well i guess i guess we could have just
removed the static assert and it would
have just used this and not done
anything actually why why why why was
the static or so false what why can't we
just do that because clearly it's going
to use this if it can but everything
else doesn't need to exist anymore
right wouldn't this make more sense
and still work
yes i don't know man i don't know what
what past me was thinking again maybe
someone who
has actually gone through that episode
more recently knows why but whatever
all right so where are we now um so now
what should happen obviously is the
scene serializer should serialize the
correct uuid and we should in fact have
a different uuid for everything now so
if we actually go to um hazelnut into
assets scenes and into physics 2d let's
say you can see we have the same uid
everywhere what i'm going to do now is
launch hazel it should generate uuids
for us right
immediately when it deserializes these
entities if we can even get the thing
building okay well this is upset now
so maybe that was
i should have probably tried linking it
not just bit not just compiling it
um
[Music]
on component added
but why doesn't it just call the
oh because the template wasn't defined
in the header file
that's why
so it actually needs it
because this we decided not to define
because i don't think we could define
specializations just in cpp files and we
probably didn't want okay yeah this is
this is annoying okay we'll keep it
we'll keep it for now but this entire
system i will rewrite later
yeah so in case you didn't follow along
the reason that i didn't link is because
this isn't defined here so it actually
needs a concrete definition for every
type it can't generate a template in the
other hazelnut module which is the exe
file okay so if we um try and load this
right if we have a quick look at this so
these are the uuids right but if i save
it now if i overwrite this so assets in
physics 2d so if i override it like this
yes
then you can see now right every one of
these is obviously different
it's unique right so i just go ahead and
quickly do this with all the other
scenes
okay so i've done it to all of the um
different scenes now they all should
have uuids and now they have uids let's
actually not regenerate them every time
right because obviously if we run it
again what's going to happen is when we
deserialize an entity inside the
serialize
so let's find the other to do it's just
still going to call msn create entity
what does that do it generates a new
uuid so we obviously need to make sure
that we're actually creating it with
with the uuid create entity with uuid
and so we'll type in taking a uuid just
by values fine it's just a 64-bit value
create implementation
um and then we're basically going to do
this
right
it's just that this uuid when we add
component you when we add this component
right it's going to be specifically this
that we add right
uh let's just make sure that
this uh should be fine right
error type okay arrow type what uuid is
an error type okay
let's include
uuid
keep it in alphabetical order
okay should be good right and then so
we'll just change this to be
return create entity with uuid
and this is going to be you so we'll
generate a uid in this case and then
we'll pass the name through as well okay
so now we're creating it with a specific
uuid
uh and that's it then we just change
this to create entity with uuid and
obviously we don't really have a way of
verifying this but it should actually
not create um you know a different one
so we'll just pass it the uuid that it
has retrieved from this yaml file right
so now we are properly serializing and
storing our uuids that we generate okay
that's it so i'm going to remove these
two do's um
and i think we're pretty much good to go
i guess we'll validate this so the way
we'll validate it quickly is we'll just
make sure the camera is always is 47939
like blah blah again right
we could serialize this as um
[Music]
hexadecimal i guess to maybe save some
bytes of text i don't know i don't
really care
i don't know
i never i never seem to care about
anything but i just don't care at the
moment okay so physics 2d that's what we
were looking at right so if we save that
and we actually override it again
right i'm hoping that we have the same
one so it changed position which is fine
but you can see camera is four seven
nine three nine right so it has in fact
remain the same see that's also why we
don't trust and or entity for any kind
of id stuff it's not built for that it
doesn't guarantee that it can change
stuff all the time and that's totally
fine that's actually totally fine we
don't care because we have our own id
system as we should for something like
this okay so now every entity that we
create is going to have its own
generated uuid which we should probably
display here somewhere in hazel in
proper hazel we if you hover your mouse
over the tag it actually pops up just in
case you want to debug it or whatever
but usually that's not really required
anyway i hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please don't forget to
hit the like button
patreon.com i'm forever grateful for all
of your lovely support
uh you'll get access of course if you
support there to the big version of
hazel and see all of these concepts
already implemented and your support is
what get what keeps this series going as
well now that we have laid down this
groundwork next time
we are going to jump in and make it so
that when we hit play and stop it
actually reverse our scene properly
we'll set up all of that runtime scene
functionality
uh i'm not going to make you guys wait a
week because next thursday actually is
when we are going to keep live streaming
and keep working on hazel so i'll
probably just make another video
throughout the week right so expect
another one in a couple days or three
days or something like that
and we should be able to get back on
track thank you guys for watching have a
great rest of your day goodbye
[Music]
you